SPEAKER 1: Once you have a
set of your APIs outfitted
with API proxies,
now is the time
to share them with
your developers
so that they can
start consuming them.
In Apigee, we refer
to the process
of getting your APIs into
the hands of your developers
as publishing your APIs.
Publication requires the
following three steps--
creating API products,
registering developers,
and registering apps.
Here's how it works.
In Apigee, an API product
is a set of API proxies
that you want to bundle
together to offer to your app
developers.
Create different API products to
address different app developer
needs.
App developers are
your API's customers,
so treat creation
of an API product
as you would any other product
you'd offer to a customer.
Next, to be able to give
app developers access
to your API products, you'll
need to register your app
developers.
If you have a developer
portal, app developers
can register themselves.
If you don't have
a developer portal,
you can use the Apigee Edge
API to provide a registration
form for app developers, or
you can register them yourself
using the Apigee Edge UI.
The final step in
enabling a developer
to access your API product is
to register a developer app.
Again, if you have
a developer portal,
an app developer can
register her app herself.
If you don't have
a developer portal,
you can use the Apigee Edge API
to provide an app registration
form for app developers,
or you can register the app
on your developer's behalf
using the Apigee Edge UI.
When registering her
app, the developer
selects the API products
that her app needs to access.
Once registered, the
developer is given a consumer
key, also known as a public
key, API key, or app key.
Each app has a single
key that provides access
to all API products
associated with the app.
The app developer codes
her app to present the key
to be able to access
the API product.
This is the simplest form
of app-based security
that you can
configure for an API.
Another useful
feature of these keys
is that you can revoke a key to
prevent an app from accessing
one or all of the API products
with which it is associated.
And there you have it--
products, developers,
and developer apps and their
keys working in conjunction
to provide targeted
access to your APIs
to your app developers.
To learn more about Apigee,
products, developers,
and developer apps, please
see the links provided.